people don't think their voice matters
but that is such such a life everyone
vote matters
you should go and vote if you're 18 or
older this election affects law your
voice does matter if you don't vote
let's say Donald Trump has one more
person if you don't vote one more
against Donald Trump he might become the
present and for the Republicans if one
more person will Chillar e Clinton then
Hillary Clinton's gonna be present I
think it's important for you to vote for
what you believe and I just stay at home
and let other people making the
decisions for you this was a land of
opportunity I feel like if Trump runs
this world is already kind of enough
messed up he can make it even worse and
Donald Trump you have fans - I'm not
saying this to offend you
I want someone honest and truthful to
run this country even though I'm not
huge for Hillary Clinton I just think
you know you gotta go with your gut no
I'm just gonna sit here firm lay down
bed need some nachos Oh mmm
shouldn't you be out there voting no
that's what happens if you don't vote
you get took him down mortal kombat slam
we want our kids to grow up in a very
happy nice place for them to live a
great life and we need to fix that and
we need a good person to run this
country go out and ow
you